all right
zyla zyla where are you from originally
where did you grow up I'm from Whittier
California Whittier tell me about your
family you had with your parents when
you were a kid yeah I live with my mom
um and I grew up in whiter and then she
remarried and then we moved to
Oregon and then I grew up in Oregon for
a little bit and then after that we
moved back to
California how would you describe your
childhood it was pretty good um I had a
pretty good upbringing I would say um I
would say though my family is a little
more
conservative cuz they don't know that
I'm trans I haven't told them yet but
they don't know yeah can they do you
talk to them on the phone yeah I do and
can they tell your voice has been well
always I mean I've always had a really
feminine voice I came out as gay at
first so like but you're taking hormones
now yeah but they don't
know that'll be one hell of a surprise
yeah maybe they'll see this
video it'll be easier to do it that way
than showing up at Thanksgiving dinner
oh my God so much easier I'm like just
go to on
YouTube so tell me about your your
childhood you you grew up and and you
you realize you were gay I didn't the
age yeah I mean I I realized that I was
different I didn't really understand
like what feeling like a woman or
feeling like born being born in the
wrong body was so I just kind of put it
in the category of gay because that's
all I kind of knew at the time but
you're you feel
more you're trans not not just gay no
yeah I'm transgender yeah it's just that
when I was younger at the time I that
was the only label that I that I kind of
knew I didn't really know what trans was
I just just like oh well I like guys and
I'm feminine and but I didn't know that
like wanting to like dress like you know
as a woman or be a woman I didn't know
what that was
yet was
it confusing or difficult for you at
all um I would say the only difficult
part was just maybe so more so just the
beginning of my transition
kind of like socially transitioning and
everything like that
um yeah cuz I I didn't always look like
as feminine obviously the hormones help
change stuff but you know I also had a
little help um I spent like around well
I didn't spend it but um my sugar daddy
he spent around like 5K on filler to
help feminize my face oh so you've been
getting help from a sugar daddy yeah and
what kind of what kind of surgeries are
you hoping to have so I've only had
filler but um I want to get my face like
actually done like you know like bone
shaved down and stuff like that and I
want so what what do they what do they
do to feminize your face so what they
would do is they would shave down well
what I want done is I want my brow bone
shaved my chin shaved my jaw shaved a
little bit fat grafting to my cheeks a
lip lift and that's it for my face and
then I want my boots done
and nothing nothing else or there um I
mean I'd like to have like maybe like a
a BBL but I'm kind of scared cuz I hear
you can like die from that I mean I know
you can die from surgery in general but
I just know the BBL is like kind of it's
a little more
dangerous tell me about your sugar daddy
is
he uh how' you meet him
online and you you were looking for a
sugar
daddy
um yeah pretty much or or you were doing
online dating and then it turned into a
sugar
D kind of yeah so I actually had just
stopped working at Mac at the time and I
was out of work um stopped working fired
kind of um and so I was out of work and
I I was like you know what do I do so I
just got on like these different dating
trans apps and like I just started
talking to these guys and
asking them for money and then I found
one who just like he just like is giving
me like a lot of money how much money is
he giving
you like whenever I ask for money he'll
send it or like it's usually like 800
per week it's pretty good yeah um before
it was a little bit more um like with
all the filler and everything but you
know he's kind of calmed down with the
spending especially cuz like I haven't
had sex with them yet so I feel like
that's a lot of money to spend on
someone when you haven't had sex how
long have you been together we've been
talking for like four months four months
and yeah no I don't plan on having sex
with him I don't like him you're playing
hard to
get
yeah but he knows your trans and that's
oh yeah of course well yeah he's the one
that helped pay for the filler to like
help feminize my face and everything
there's so many different kinds of
relationships I don't know exactly what
what everyone knows or what everyone's
what everyone's role is
yeah how have you made money before that
through I've always worked like my whole
life like ever since I was 18 I've
always had a job but the sex work is
something new
or um yeah I've dabbled in sex work um
but with him like I haven't had sex with
him at all so that's nice he just gives
me he's just your sugar daddy yeah
that's the best kind of sugar daddy I
think yeah but I only have
one you need five I know I want like
20 and you're staying here on
skro unfortunately yeah at the Madison
are are drugs part of your I only do
Weed and Alcohol nothing else nothing
else yeah I'm a healthy
girl what what was your childhood like
with with when you were coming
out
so when I came out as gay my mom was
like okay well that's fine but you just
have to you know Hush Hush very like
don't tell anyone you know what you do
behind your
own closed doors is your business
whatever um but then like I started you
know really wanting to like be myself
and I would start to like wear makeup in
secret um and then when I turned 18 like
I I went to the mall with my friend one
day and I bought a foundation you know
without my mom knowing and then I was
like [__] it I'm just going to come home
and you know just be myself and like
with the makeup on and everything and
just like not care cuz I was so tired of
like not being able to be myself like I
was always so quiet around my family
just cuz like I wasn't able to be myself
and I was just you know I was 18 so I
was like oh I'm an adult like I'm tired
of this you know so then I came home
home and immediately my mom was like
what is that on your face and I was like
it's makeup and she was like you need to
wash it off right now and I was like no
I'm going to wash it off like when I
want to you know just being rebellious
or
whatever and then my mom got really
angry and she was like you know you need
to take that off right now you can't
live under my roof if you have on makeup
like you're a boy you can't wear makeup
or
whatever um obviously not knowing that I
was trains at the time and then so after
that she just had like a huge long talk
with my stepdad and like she like
finally we we like kind of had a talk
and she was like yeah well if you want
to you know do this and wear makeup you
can't live here like you can't be like
living here cuz that's like the rules
and I was like okay fine I'll just go
live somewhere else and at the at the
time this is kind of crazy because I had
just gotten in contact with my real dad
and I had never I had never spoken with
him like until I was 18 and he like
contacted me through Facebook and then
um like so I was like fine I'll just go
live with him so I ended up going to
live with him and it was this huge deal
like um more so I guess me living with
him cuz I guess my mom didn't think that
like I had that you know backup plan cuz
she didn't even know that like I had
talked to him until I told her which was
also a huge like deal she would like she
basically said I like backstabbed her
for talking to
him um so yeah then I went to go live
with him
and my dad was living with his parents
at the time his mom has paranoid
schizophrenia so that's a little crazy
and I didn't know that like weird
dynamic in their household like his dad
had to take care of his mom for a long
time like uh you know till now you know
he still taking care of her um and she
has paranoid schizophrenia so like
that's not a really ideal situation to
be living with like you know his parents
and like dealing with that
so so I ended up like I had a best
friend at the time her name was Sarah so
I ended up inviting Sarah to come live
with me like just because like I don't
know I needed a friend and I was like oh
you can come stay with me cuz my dad is
like cool or whatever and like you know
it's a crazy household you know she just
parner schizophrenia it'll be fine wrong
my grandpa got so mad like he was like
you know she can't stay here like you
know I'm taking care of someone who has
paranoid schizophrenia and it's making
it worse like you adding someone that
she doesn't know he was like it's okay
that you're here because you know your
family but you inviting someone to just
come live with us is like not good and
then I felt bad because I basically told
her to come live with me so now she
doesn't have a place to stay so we ended
up living in my
car and that was a whole big thing and
then after that like I basically did
that for 3 months with her and it was
like super difficult um we would shower
at the gym we would like use our EBT to
get you know food but we were basically
getting like malnutrition because we
were only eating like chips and like
fruit and like snacks so
um then I found out about the LGBT
Center at the time I think it was like
on Highland and now they like moved it
but I stayed there when I moved to LA
cuz I had heard about the LGBT Center
like that they give housing um and then
I started staying there and then from
there I moved to Covenant House which is
another housing thing for Youth and then
from there I stayed at Salvation Army
which my family has no idea about like
my mom mom at the time she just thought
that like I was staying like with like
roommates and stuff she had no idea that
I was like staying at like the LGBT
Center and then covenant house and then
Salvation Army she had no
idea and I was still talking to her at
the time and also at that time too um
like I was still identifying as gay but
like wearing
makeup and
yeah where would you like to be in five
years
in five
years I would say I want to I want to
definitely be done with my transition
completely like all my surgery's done um
and maybe even have like a little bit of
like a career in makeup cuz I really do
like doing makeup like I used to work at
Sephora for a really long time and then
I worked for Mac um now I'm a sugar baby
but I would like to do something in
makeup again career-wise
considering that you still have a lot of
work to do you're very convincing as a
as as a CIS female as they call it
thanks that's a really big
compliment I feel like I look I don't
know it's crazy because I feel like I
look so masculine
but so being trans is it's this is just
something that you you are yeah this is
not something that is fixable or
something that you're going to change
your mind down later or anything like
that yeah yeah no this is who I
am and there are guys who are into that
right oh yeah yeah they call them like
the
Chasers so you have you still have some
male parts oh yeah and is that something
you're looking to keep or
lose um I feel like for I don't know I
feel like that's such a sensitive topic
it's such a
major
surgery um
and for me I feel like my dysphoria
doesn't it's not too bad like down well
I think there are a lot of trans people
who prefer to be a little bit of this
and a little bit of that yeah I think
for me think it's desirable for a lot of
yeah I mean I think maybe when I was a
little younger I think that's kind of
the route that I wanted to go but as I'm
getting older and I think now I'm a
little
more fine if it's like if I don't have
that surgery you know and you know who
knows down the line I may want kids so I
may want to like freeze my sperm or
something cuz I know that's that's like
a big thing too is if you get the
surgery or even like now I would
probably need to like freeze my sperm
since I am on hormones if I did want
kids
later but I have I have a kid now yes my
baby D she's very cute thank you and how
do the hormones change you either
emotionally or
physically I would say I
feel definitely physical changes here
and there um like fat
redistribution um but I would say the
mental changes like I cry a lot and I'm
really sensitive now like or like I'll
just start crying like if I like think
about something that you shouldn't that
you wouldn't be crying about um normally
so I would say those are like the
biggest
changes that I've noticed oh and of
course like boob growth and
stuff do you have any regrets no no
regrets no none in fact I feel like I'm
happier now than I was be like before I
started hormones and like filler and
everything like I'm a lot happier now
for sure how old are you a lot more
confident 27 27 what's your biggest
fear that's a good
one I don't
know I don't want to say it cuz I feel
like you if you say it you speak it into
existence no you don't have to say it
then okay that's all right I won't
pressure
you and Z what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important
lesson I would say
just be yourself from the very beginning
even if you feel like it's like scary or
if your family doesn't accept you if
your friends don't accept you if you
know your significant other you know is
you're with doesn't accept you anyone
you know I would say [__] them and just
focus on you and be yourself because
you're going to be so much happier in
the end the world seems to be changing a
Lot quickly
yeah
so that that just bodess well for
somebody who has some shocking news for
their family on
Thanksgiving
yeah I'll just send them the link to to
this good luck with that all right s
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you wish you lots of luck thank
you
thanks